okay let's go
here johnny depp is in a defamation case
against his ex-wife amber heard and um
i haven't followed the case that close
because i don't care all that much but i
thought this was interesting yesterday
here's audio of his wife
um and they've both got audio and video
of each other they've just been filming
and
documenting each other apparently
throughout their marriage it's really a
healthy sign of a healthy marriage is
when you're constantly you constantly
feel the need to secretly record your
spouse so here's one recording of uh
johnny depp's wife ex-wife now amber
heard admitting that
she hit him although she has an
interesting
distinction that she tries to draw in
order to justify the abuse but listen
i said to you
hey
tell travis what just happened are you
telling me to do it you told me to you
said go do that i said no tell him what
you're saying i lied that you punched me
in the
thing you figured it out and you said
i'm sorry that i didn't
uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
babe you're not punched don't tell me
what it feels like to be punched you
know even a lot of fights been around a
long time i don't know
you didn't get punched you got hit i'm
sorry i hit you like this but i did not
punch you i did not [ __ ] deck you i
was hitting you i don't know what the
motion of my actual hand was but you're
fine i did not hurt you i did not punch
you i was hitting you how are you how
what am i supposed to do do this
i'm not sitting here thinking about it
am i you are that's the difference
between me and you your baby
because you started you are such a baby
[Applause]
okay
these are just such broken
people in hollywood
broken empty
people which is why their marriages
never work out
you take two broken empty people and you
put them in a marriage together it's
very rarely is going to work um
so her
argument is that uh i didn't punch you i
hit you so that's i'm not i'm not quite
sure i understand the distinction
between the two things
and a couple things here first of all i
know part of amber heard's claim is that
she was abused and
terrorized by
and terrified of
johnny depp but you listen to audio like
that and it's that's i don't exactly
hear a woman who's terrified of her
husband or who's abused when when she's
admitting to physically striking him and
and
is mocking him
does that seem like a woman who's afraid
of her husband
i just hit you you're being a big baby
is that what you say when you're afraid
of somebody
but then the other thing of course is
that is that the the massive
[Music]
the
massive glaring double standard
and if there's a double standard with
anything it is with this it is with uh
situations like this marital disputes
especially domestic abuse issues
you just
imagine that audio the other way imagine
there's audio of johnny depp
saying to amber heard i didn't i didn't
punch you i hit you you big baby can you
imagine that if that audio was out there
but we have that of amber heard and
there are still they're actually people
that still take her side
because even the people
and indeed in fact actually especially
the people
who claim that men and women are exactly
the same there's no difference this
distinction is entirely arbitrary
um
they say that and yet they just they do
not put
mail on fema they don't put female on
male domestic abuse nearly on the same
plane as male 1
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content